I am excited guys I'm excited I just did
this I just went to the Wizarding World
of Harry Potter everybody walking around
I was having a great time and then a
group of tourists children all looked at
me and in unison they were like they
mistook me for the fat groundskeeper
guys there that is and the best part is
all the parents came over like oh my God
we're so sorry our kids think you're
happy but will you please take pictures
[Applause]
eighteen photographs just standing
behind them posing like a regular dude
my JC the black album shirt
I'm excited dogs I know we're like four
or five years these kids are flipping
through family photos they're gonna be
like who the hell is this guy why am I
sitting on his shoulders I have a
roommate he just bought that little
robot Alexa well computer you can
chitchat with and Alexa is terrible at
listening she's bad at it and me and my
roommate we share a bedroom wall so when
he gets home from work it just sounds
like he's in an abusive relationship
you watch things like Alexa turn the
lights on Alexa why did I even buy you
slow it down but neighbors don't know
you're yelling at a robot not to mention
it's time for us to start being polite
to the robot so whatever he goes to work
in the morning guys pop my head in the
room like hey Alexa you doing okay
I heard drag yelling at you just wanted
to let you know I'm one of the good
humans tell Skynet when you talk to her
[Applause]
I was drinking last night drinking my
favorite kind of booze I love vodka
that's my favorite yeah armie hammer
fans over there yeah I love it I love it
cuz you can mix it with anything make it
taste delicious and then drink too much
of it that's my favorite I get drunk
like an 18 year old white girl rushing a
southern sorority that's all
and that's how I behave at the end of
the night I'm going stumbling out of the
bar like that's just a regular Tuesday
night everybody's trying to be more of
an adult I'm failing at it I just did
this to be more of a grown-up I just
gave a framed poster of the rapper DMX
to Goodwill there it is guys that's who
I was not who I am not that guy can't be
thirty years old and have a framed
poster of a shirtless rapper surrounded
by pit bulls and chains hanging above
your bed can't do it regular women walk
in ago I was already if he about this
but absolutely hot gonna be thinking
about him barking the whole time I
couldn't help myself before I took it to
Goodwill I pried open the frame and I
tucked a fake treasure map into the back
of the forehead
some of you were following I like it I'm
just excited cuz I'm hoping the same
person who buys a framed poster from
Goodwill will follow a treasure map they
find in the back of said frame cut to 30
years from now a big site outside of New
Mexico a young man throws his shovel
down in disgust an old man creeps up
behind it with his game grabs him by the
scruff of his circles oh you didn't know
we're looking for the trash you
[Applause]
[Music]
and here
you